it's the sound of the wind skipping
across a desert campfire or the waves on
a tranquil Beach as the Sun sets the
nigh or reed flute is one of the world's
oldest musical instruments paintings on
the walls of Pharaohs tombs show ancient
Egyptians playing it the reeds are
coming directly from nature we just
clean it make it straight and it's an
instrument ready to use this idea for me
was kind of magical that the earth is
giving us an instrument to hear the land
Rabi Azura COTS passion for the NIE is
rooted in his reverence for the Arabic
music of his ancestors five years ago he
decided he wanted to learn how to play
the NIE however he couldn't find the
instrument or a teacher in Jordan even
though the reeds grow in the valley of
the Jordan River he was saddened that an
instrument that literally grew from his
country's land and was enjoyed by
generations of Jordanians was in danger
of becoming an artifact he spent days
searching for the reeds in the wild and
learned how to make and play the nine I
taught me that life is more diverse
because there is no reed like the other
every reed is like a different
personality treet I learn using the
rocket co-founded the house of nye in
2017 to revive the instrument through
lessons and concerts don't be fooled by
this simple looking instrument I still
haven't been able to make a sound come
out
Zurich OTT says he wants people to feel
comfortable picking this up and playing
it without aiming for perfection to
spread this traditional Arabic music the
house of nye has been holding workshops
in and outside of a man reaching
hundreds of jordanians 16 year-old tariq
raba attended one of those workshops in
the small town of as rack now he teaches
other children
is hoping to become a cultural
ambassador bharata's regret fear and I
want to attract tourists to enjoy the
environment of as Rach teaching them to
play the nie is giving them a window
into the musical culture of as RAC
connecting the past with the present
crafting something from nature and
savoring the music across the
generations Zurich I'd hopes he's
reigniting an appreciation of an art
form that transcends music and can
continue for many more millennia
Natasha ganene al Jazeera a man
[Music]